REGIONS OF THE WORLD?
>> Bret: MR. AMBASSADOR, WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
WE WELCOME YOU BACK ANYTIME.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE THIS
EVENING.
>> Bret: WALL STREET TOOK A
HIT TODAY.
THE NEWS OF THE TARIFFS FROM
CHINA TOOK IT PRETTY HARD.
THE PRESIDENT'S PRESS SPOKESMAN
SAYS PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL FIGHT
BACK.
IT IS THE LATEST SALVO IN THE
GROWING TRADE DISPUTES, WHICH
SOME FEEL COULD LEAD TO AN ALL
OUT TRADE WERE AMONG THE WORLDS
CORRESPONDENT RICH EDSON HAS
ELITIST AND I FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
>> CHINA, THE WORLD'S LARGEST
PORK CONSUMER.
LESTER, AMERICAN PIG FARMERS AND
SOLD NEARLY $700 MILLION OF
THEIR PARK TO CHINA.
CHINA JUST ANNOUNCED THAT SAME
MEAT WILL BE 25% MORE EXPENSIVE.
>> WE EXPORT MORE THAN 26% OF
ALL U.S. PORK PRODUCTION OUTSIDE
OF OUR BORDERS.
ANY DISRUPTION TO AN IMPORTANT
MARKET LIKE CHINA IS BAD NEWS
FOR U.S. HOG FARMERS.
>> CHINA'S MINISTRY OF COMMERCE
IT SAYS IT'S IMPOSING TARIFFS ON
128 AMERICAN PRODUCTS SOLD IN
CHINA, PUSHING UP THE PRICE OF
THOSE GOODS AND PRESENTING A
SUBSTANTIAL DISADVANTAGE TO
AMERICAN MANUFACTURERS AND
FARMERS.
CHINA ANNOUNCED A 15% TARIFF ON
U.S. FRUIT, WINE, STEEL PIPES,
AND OTHER PRODUCTS.
120 IN TOTAL.
25% IMPORT FEE ON EIGHT OTHERS
LIKE PORK AND RECYCLED ALUMINUM.
THIS IS IN RESPONSE TO TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TARIFFS ON
ALUMINUM AND STEEL IMPORTS FROM
CHINA AND OTHER COUNTRIES.
THE WHITE HOUSE JUSTIFIES THOSE
TARIFFS, CLAIMING THEY'LL
ADDRESS THE ANNUAL $350 BILLION
U.S. TRADE DEFICIT WITH CHINA.
>> IT'S TAKING OUR INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY, AND THE PRESIDENT WILL
FIGHT BACK AND WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH THEM TO MAKE
SURE WE ARE GETTING A GOOD DEAL
AND THAT WE ARE NOT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF PRIDE >> CHINA SAYS
IT'S TARIFFS GET ABOUT -- A
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF MORE THAN
$130 BILLION IN GOODS THE
UNITED STATES SENT TO CHINA.
THOUGH ANALYSTS AND FREE-TRADE
ADVOCATES SAY THEY WORRY ABOUT
THE NEXT STEP.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS ALSO
THREATENED TO TAX $60 BILLION IN
IMPORTS.
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT SAYS THAT
COST U.S. BUSINESSES BETWEEN 225
AND $600 BILLION A YEAR.
DISCUSSIONS CONTINUE BETWEEN THE
GOVERNMENT, AMERICAN PRODUCERS
SAY THEY WANT THE U.S. AND CHINA
TO RESOLVE THIS SOON.
>> THERE ARE 550,000 JOBS IN
RURAL AMERICA THAT ARE TIED
DIRECTLY TO THE U.S. PORK
INDUSTRY.
110,000 OF THOSE JOBS ARE
DIRECTLY TIED TO EXPORTS.
SO IMPORTANT FOR THE GROWTH OF
OUR INDUSTRY AND ECONOMY.
>> THERE ARE ALSO NATIONAL
SECURITY CONCERNS.
CHINA IS KEY TO UPCOMING TALKS
WITH NORTH KOREA.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS JUST
ANNOUNCED THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
WILL SOON MEET WITH THE LEADER
OF A TOP COMPETITOR IN THE
REGION FOR CHINA, JAPANESE